joining us here for draft week as his
pro football focus team has been
fantastic
and their information is first-rate and
must-have certainly
during the talent evaluation portion of
the calendar that culminates with the
draft on thursday night
chris collinsworth of nbc sports and pro
football focus here on the rich eisen
show how are you chris
rich for about 1.3
seconds yes sir about the time it takes
you to run the 40. thank you
i thought i was the sexiest man alive
thank you
how special did you feel interpreted it
and it didn't last
long but you know i had i had that
moment
i had that moment and i was the sexiest
man alive for 1.3 hey look the eye
doesn't uh eye in the sky doesn't lie
chris you know what i mean see what i'm
saying uh
thanks for joining me here on on the
show today uh i
i can't wait to hear your uh analysis of
this quarterback
class that um that we we
i think we can all agree trevor lawrence
being first overall makes sense
do you think the jets are making the
right maneuver with zach wilson should
the expected happen on thursday night
chris i do yeah as a matter of fact
by greater debate with zach wilson and
trevor lawrence no kidding
um i i think i think those two are
clearly set apart
uh and deserve to be so uh you're going
to see
zach wilson unless i'm totally screwing
this up
sort of aaron rodgers you know that
that's what he's going to feel like i
think to most people who are watching
him play
wow i mean that that is that's a manhole
cover you just threw around like there
man so
what what's yours no i not that i think
he's going to be
as good or as great or as whatever but
the style of play
the sort of off platform the kind of
i don't want to say this in an insulting
way to the host of jeopardy but
that like i can do things you can't do
kind of throws
and just like like playing with the
defense
kind of thing now he didn't get hit very
much at byu
so maybe that changes in the nfl but i i
think people are going to really enjoy
watching him play and he would
absolutely be
second if if i didn't take trevor
lawrence so you certainly have piqued my
curiosity by saying that the evaluation
debate
um for you sits atop this draft i mean
walk me through zach wilson versus
trevor lawrence that made you
sort of go back and forth on the subject
the bottom line was i i thought they
were both equally good players
i i didn't i didn't my evaluation wasn't
one over the other
um but it was really for me it was
the body of work for trevor lawrence you
know i've seen him play against the best
college players in the world i had seen
him in championship games i had seen him
when he got knocked down i had seen him
when they lost big games i had seen him
when he won big games
and with zach wilson that body of work
is
sort of coastal carolina ish you know
it's like
you just got to be careful what you're
putting in and the class of athletes
that they're playing
against but i i do think he has that
kind of talent
i think he has that sort of charisma to
the quarterback position if you will
but trevor lawrence has just done it for
too long a period of time
and too consistently for him not to be
the first thing chris collinsworth here
on the rich eisen show let's get to
three overall
cause you know i i've had a hard time
wrapping my
mind around the concept that the 49ers
made that huge move up to three
for an evaluation period amongst a group
of quarterbacks they'd be
fine with you know what i'm saying like
i i i still can't
comprehend that they're not gonna just
hand in the car to the guy that they
knew they were gonna take the day they
consummated the trade on zack wilson's
pro day
what do you think is happening with the
niners and their evaluation of that
position
chris i'd say this is one of the more
bizarre ones i've ever
seen um i i for
all that i know and i haven't talked to
anybody in san francisco so i
i rely on those guys for a lot of
information during the season
i leave them alone during the draft
season um
but it is i thought when they made the
move it was justin fields
when i when i look at kyle's offense
i always think what if
they had a mobile guy coming out of the
back end of that so
their offense is simply this they're
going to have a running back who runs
under 4-4 with that outside zone stretch
then they're going to go play action
bootleg off of it make you cover the
backside
rpos all the different things but i
always thought
what if you had the extreme
right assuming stretch play right what
if you had
play action bootleg and you had to
protect the backside throwing lanes the
slants the hooks all that
stuff back in there and then you had a
guy like justin fields who i think
is a dynamo running the ball i i love
watching him play the game
if you had him or trey lance coming out
of the back end of that
thing and so when they made the trade i
go you know what i get it
jimmy garoppolo and matt ryan can take
you so far but if you had that last
element
coming around the backside it could be
really pretty special
uh in in my mind just watching the tape
and i haven't met these guys i don't
i don't know them but you know i hear
that trey lance is just this
really smart guy and so is mac jones and
but when you just put on the tape
uh justin fields as far as a physical
specimen to me was still the one that
stuck out i thought his accuracy
was really fantastic but his running
skills and running ability
he's got a long way to go as far as
reading the defenses
and not reading them but not going
first read run you know that and that's
what young quarterbacks do a lot of
uh so though if the first reads not
there he's gonna take off at rod
uh but i also think that kyle's probably
the best
or one of the best quarterback coaches
in all the league and i just go
i got it that makes total sense to me
i've got it i've got it figured out
and then they said mac jones and i was
like really did you have to go all the
way to three to get matt jones right
so it was really it's still confusing to
me and now
the latest thing i read was that maybe
they're going to go
frey lance because there's like so much
pressure in san francisco to not take
mac jones and so the scouts like
trey lance and it's like oh my goodness
this thing has just
gone crazy here chris collinsworth here
on the rich eisen show and i'm just
putting together
everything that we've gleaned here over
the several weeks of just focusing on
this right here on this show
you know bucky brooks my colleague from
the nfl media group
saying that you you know you don't trade
up
all that to get somebody who wasn't even
the best player
on the field on his own team in mack
jones
who he said was like uh you know iron
man where
the the program and the coaching staff
and the other players around him are the
suit that made him great
kurt warner saying that you don't take
uh
that big leap to get somebody who is
similar to the guy that you have you
need to take somebody who is physically
somebody completely different uh with a
bigger upside and then i'm
hearing dan olofsky say if you think
that mac jones isn't an improvement over
jimmy garoppolo you're crazy
so what is your evaluation of mac from
what you see
chris the first thing i wrote down about
mac jones is why why don't people love
him
right that was my first evaluation
like when you watch him play he's an
accurate guy
he can move fairly well he can hit he
can make some big runs
if you if you need them but i would
agree with the evaluation
of you know is it different than what
you
have or have had in this offense you
know rg3 back in the day
could do some of that in his rookie year
coming out the the back side of this
thing
um but i i i don't think
i don't think that mac jones adds an
element that you
don't truly have assuming garoppolo can
stay healthy
now the the back end side of this thing
is
you know i keep seeing garoppolo back in
new england and i don't know how he's
getting there
so if you take if you take mac jones
could matt jones be ready for opening
date yeah
probably i could see that if you took if
you took
justin fields or trey lance would you
prefer
them having a year behind jimmy
garoppolo
and i would say yeah i probably would
prefer that so
you know i i think it a little bit of it
depends on are they really serious about
jimmy garoppolo
hanging in there and being the
quarterback this year and developing
one of those two guys which is a very
you know
very thoughtful plan or do you go i want
mac jones because ultimately i want to
flip
jimmy garoppolo to the patriots for a
bunch of draft picks and then go build
the rest of my team so
there's something going on here that we
don't all collectively know
um but it's it's one of the more
interesting top of the drafts that i've
ever seen chris collinsworth here on the
rich eisen show and what to make of
lance
chris i mean again he doesn't have much
tape uh
period let alone uh recently but
uh everything i'm hearing and he's gonna
be on tomorrow's show i can't wait to
interview him
is his inquisitiveness his size his
quickness his speed
everything together makes him the guy
with maybe the biggest upside of
everybody
in the draft and you know everything
that you just said about what about a
shanahan offense that could have
somebody
creating a misdirection and then going a
different way and now you've got to
actually cover him uh not just because
of his arm
it's fascinating to me what's your
evaluation of trey lance with you in pff
chris absolutely huge arm um
uh he reminds me a little bit throwing
the ball of colin kaepernick if you
remember colin had a little bit of that
three-quarter stuff a little bit that uh
you know that there were some accuracy
issues but he brought so much else to
the table
you know and colin kaepernick had one of
the greatest
quarterback games i've ever seen we did
a game in new england
and i i went down for the pre-game show
with
with uh bob costas and we were sitting
in the tunnel and i mean rich it's just
one of those days
where it was like 30 degrees the wind
was like 40 miles an hour
we were all just freezing sort of this
misty sleeting
kind of rain not quite snow
i went back up to the booth and i told
al i go i go i'm telling you this game
at best is 10-7 it ended up like 41-37
with colin kaepernick out dueling tom
brady coming down the stretch one of the
great
quarterback games i've ever seen in my
life so i'm not putting down colin
kaepernick
but i if i had to put him in a category
i think trey lance is probably
even a little more athletic version of
colin kaepernick i thought you were
going with
the playoff game against green bay i
don't know if you called that game but i
thought that i did call that game but
that was pretty good too
yeah this is just one that stuck out in
my mind because i was so
convinced with the conditions that
nobody was going to move the ball and
they just
killed it yeah and i guess if you do
take the concept that garoppolo could be
the guy which is what shanahan said in a
press conference at a very truthful
press conference after the trade was
done
that if you know jimmy g's popular in
the locker room they can carry his
freight
cap wise and let treyland sit there i
mean that
that because he definitely from all the
evaluators needs some definite
sit time and and and and learning and
to get up to speed man that would be the
answer have you
have you been keeping up with the crowd
the you know
sort of what the the people in san
francisco want
i mean it sounds like there's going to
be a revolution if they end up taking
mack jones and there's nothing wrong
with
with sticking to your guns right i've
known the shanahan's my whole life
mike was my coach back in college at the
university of florida
so they stick to their guns pretty good
but the pressure is building to the
point now where you start going man
if they made that deal and they get mac
jones and that didn't work
out and you know you started
extrapolating that thing out
um so i don't know i i really i still
don't know what they're gonna do
in the few minutes i have left with you
chris i want the evaluation for two more
teams let's start with atlanta
what a big decision they've got it for
um after the three quarterbacks go off
the board do they take one of the two
remaining ones start the clock on matt
ryan's departure
on the spot uh julio jones apparently is
could be a cap
trade casualty they might try to figure
out how to get him signed
or do you go kyle pitts what do you do
if you're atlanta
chris what do you think i'm gonna tell
you what
i can only tell you what i would do i
mean atlanta's in capped hell
right now i mean they really are they've
got to dump some salary and start
rebuilding this thing um i would put
a sign out if i were the atlanta falcons
and the cincinnati bengals and at four
and five
and i would say i am not keeping this
pick
whoever offers me the most for one of
these quarterbacks
i am definitely making that trade
because i don't want i don't want people
thinking
you can end up trading with miami or
detroit
at six or seven and you're
you're going to be able to get one of
these quarterbacks now you want one
i'm definitely trading out to somebody
wants a quarterback and if i were the
bengal sitting right by them
i would do the exact same thing and see
if i couldn't because i think that
then you would end up with the entire
draft behind you
and some solid players there are some
sol i think i happen to think
that pitts and jamar chase are even
above
solid with very little risk to them
but i would want i would want to trade
down because i think the rest of the
first round
after the first seven or eight players
are all
okay are all good players but i don't
find myself at the end of this draft
going like i usually do
like oh my god i've left ten first round
draft kicks
out of the first round when i did my
mock draft
i find myself in picks 20 through
32 going now who can i put in the first
round and who do i really believe in
without much doubt and without injury
factors and uh
so i i i wouldn't even mind trading back
in the next year because i just have a
feeling that
this will be remembered other than the
quarterbacks and two or three ample
players as being a good not a great
draft because that was my last one was
the bengals you know we had carson
palmer on last week he said take penny
sewell and don't don't even look in the
direction of
of chase let's just say that they don't
trade out that people don't knock on
their door for that other quarterback
and that the bengals are have the choice
of protecting
joe burrow or getting him a weapon with
whom he's quite familiar in chase what
would you do
i know what joe burrow would do i i
talked to joe on my podcast
not too long ago and not that he came
out
and said that he wanted jamar chase but
you could tell
they were like buddies you know they
were like friends they were
magical together at lsu and then chase
turned around and ran that 437 i said
did that surprise you
he goes yeah because i i knew he was a
great player
i i and he could do phenomenal things at
the catch point i didn't know he could
run like that
um and pine school is gonna be that good
too but i i i would take
any of these top three tackles and feel
pretty good about
getting a tackle so if i had to slide
myself back down
you know three four five slots if i were
the bengals
i would feel pretty darn good about that
tackle position if that's where i wanted
to go you're referring to your podcast
with richard sherman right the chris
collinsworth podcast
good stuff man he richard's turf what's
he going to do
what do you think he's going to do this
year i think a bunch of these guys are
going to get signed after the draft you
know
when you listen to richard talk about it
uh you know everybody tells them the
same thing it's you know everybody
thinks they're going to find a 22 year
old to replace
and you know at half the price or a
tenth of the price or whatever
and then a lot of them don't end up with
somebody they can replace them and then
all these veteran players who are still
sitting out there
come back into the mix and you know at a
much lower price and
but with richard richards so talented he
can do anything he could probably go
make as much money working in
television as he is you know going out
there and playing the game so it'll be
interesting to see what happens the
chris collinsworth podcast featuring
richard sherman where all podcasts can
be acquired at collinsworth pff
on twitter and then of course on sunday
night football which we can't wait to
hear the schedule for
on on may 12th that's right around the
corner after the draft thanks for the
time chris i always
cherish our chats thank you great great
fun back at you that's chris
collinsworth
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here